hello friends and welcome to the weekly
catch-up on YouTube where we bring you
guys the biggest news of the week in
movies and TV and this week there were
so much news so with some major casting
news so the Lord of the Rings TV show
there was a new Morbius trailer and
knives out could be getting a sequel so
here we go we shoot shoot
hold on to your hobbits friends hold on
to your Hobbit Amazon's Lord of the
Rings TV series has officially announced
15 cast members it's like a quinceanera
so let's take a look at what these
latest casting details tell us about the
series right now on the catch up so
bt-dubs amazon has not finished casting
for the Lord of the Rings series which
costs him a cool 250 million for the
rights but we finally know who most of
the main cast is thanks to a major
announcement at this month's Television
Critics Association press tour starting
with Robert Armijo who played a young
Ned Stark in the certified fresh' sixth
and seventh seasons of Game of Thrones
so the good ones burn no attendance the
actor reportedly replaced will Poulter
who had to back out due to scheduling
conflicts Poulter was apparently playing
a lead role with many on social media
hoping that he would be a young Elrond
for obvious reasons but Aramaic
character has been referred to as belled
or in past reports but nothing has been
confirmed but can we just talk about the
fact that Bell door is the most Lord of
the Rings a sounding name ever you have
only one choice also speaking out super
Lord of the Rings II sounding names
Morfitt Clarke was cast in a major role
from the certified fresh' HBO show his
dark material now she will reportedly
portray the young version of Galadriel
who was played by Cate Blanchett and
Peter Jackson films and this makes sense
for the show setting which is in the
second age considering Galadriel is over
7,000 years old by the time the movie
takes place
I guess 7000 is the new 40 even the
wisest Kenneth another recognizable face
cast in the series is Joseph Maul now
you may know him as vengeance star from
Game of Thrones who eventually
sacrificed himself to save his nephew
Jon Snow
Variety reported in October that sources
say he will play a villain named Oren
though no character in the source
material appears to be named Orange
and some are wondering if he could be a
part of the Rangers of the north or just
the Rangers which is what Aragorn was in
the movies just ask your nerd friends
they'll know all about it
other notable castings include Mark
Kelly Cavanaugh who back in July was
said to be in talks to play a character
called Tyra another name new to
middle-earth and Nazanin Boniadi who has
played major roles on shows like
homeland and the stars hit counterpart
will also be a key player you don't know
these people like I do they don't
tolerate mistakes so while it will be
based on the fictional realm in which
JRR Tolkien's Lord of the Rings takes
place it seems the show will be
introducing plenty of new characters
into that world and the big-budget
fantasy series has definitely stocked up
on GOG veterans both in front of and
behind the camera which is smart because
it will be competing with shows like
Netflix is The Witcher
Apple TV plus s/c and at least one new
Game of Thrones prequel in the coming
years all vying to be the next great
fantasy series now that it's a
competition or anything but it's totally
a competition we will defeat
oscar-winning director Peter Jackson has
confirmed that he won't be involved in
the series but Shores JD Payne and
Patrick McKay along with director J
avianna who will direct the first two
episodes are often running with a table
read already under their belt and
production beginning next month plus
season 2 is already greenlit so Hobbit
dog it's gonna be fun
they made me say that what have I got in
my pocket alright friends it's time to
kick it over to you now are you excited
about this cast and will this show be
the next king of the fantasy series let
us know your thoughts in the comment
section and for all the updates from
this year's TCA pressed or check out Ron
Tomatoes calm
the marvelous Mobius movie morning great
news the first trailer for the Morpheus
movie has landed and it ends with a
major bombshell that could be telling us
a lot about the future of Sony and MCU
so let's talk about our favorite
dysfunctional relationship right now on
the ketchup the more B's trailer gave us
a first look at Jared Leto as genius
scientist dr. Michael Morbius who
accidentally becomes a living vampire
monster while trying to create a cure
for his rare blood disease can you just
hate when that happens
but it's the shot of Michael Keegan at
the end of the trailer that has everyone
talking because you know Michael Keaton
plays vulture the villain from
spider-man homecoming in MCU movie mine
below well after venom kicked things off
in 2018 Morbius will be the second film
in Sony's Marvel Universe and the thing
is venom didn't include any references
to spider-man at home so Qian is
appearing as vulture which has yet to be
confirmed that could be the key to
linking the two universes together
unless of course he's just playing
Birdman and in that case hello confusing
and considering Marvel chief Kevin Feige
seemed to tease a potential crossover
back when the latest deal for spider-man
was announced hopefully this is not a
coincidence they want to do that test
right the trailer references both the
Tom Hollands spider-man movies and venom
so seems like a good sign that our
friendly neighborhood Tom will start
popping up in the Sony movies come on
man please and fans of the comics know
that spider-man and Morbius actually
have some history with blade who is
joining the MCU in phase 4 so perhaps in
rehearsal Olli appearance could be in
store at some point down the line this
is getting wild as far as how vulture
could be connected to Morbius it might
have something to do with Keaton's
character heading to jail at the end of
homecoming and this shot of Leto from
the trailer wearing a prison uniform
maybe they flew out together that or
he's just doing an impression of Bugs
Bunny what's up doc and if you take a
look at that same shot you'll see some
spider-man graffiti in the background
this is confirmation that spider-man
does exist in Sony's Marvel Universe and
the word murder could be referring to
the MCU spider-man who we last saw being
framed for murder by Mysterio at the end
and far from home but it's also worth
pointing out that graffiti Spidey looks
less like Tom Hollands version and more
like the Sam
ramie tobey maguire era spider-man so
who knows maybe McGuire could make a
comeback can you imagine I'm so much and
speaking of the Raimi era spider-man
films don't forget that all this
crossover business really started when j
jonah Jameson played by JK Simmons made
his return to the world of spider-man at
the end of far from home which was one
of his best jaw-dropping movie moments
of 2019 and now he's rumored to be
bringing Jay Jonah to the Morbius film
as well well let me tell you something
kid you're no hero Morbius is directed
by daniel espinosa and scheduled to be
released on july 31st with the andy
serkis directed venom 2 scheduled after
that for October 2nd so if Morbius does
contain crossovers and movies as well
fingers crossed the possibilities for
future crossovers are endless and
there's plenty of potential coming up
with a third Tom Holland spider-man film
in 2021 a Kraven the hunter movie
supposedly still in development and an
entire animated spider-verse that's just
getting started with a seat will do out
in 2022
be sure to check out our episode on all
things animated spider-verse if you
haven't already okay now that you're
officially a Spidey expert it's time to
kick it over to you now what did you
think of the end of the Morbius trailer
and would you be excited for Sony MCU
crossovers let us know in the comments
section and for more movie news check
out Ron Tomatoes calm I think you have
something you want to tell me one of the
best original movies of 2019 dives out
has a sequel in the works and unlike the
ss7 movies it looks like Daniel Craig
will be coming back so let's talk about
what could go down in another round of
whodunit right now on to catch up not
only is knives out certified fresh at
97% it is now our official golden tomato
Award winner for best reviewed thriller
movie of 2019 so congratulations
insert applause here the fellas
nominated for three Golden Globes
including Best Picture Musical or Comedy
and at a pre-party thrown by the movie
studio Lionsgate writer director Rian
Johnson confirmed to The Hollywood
Reporter that he was already writing a
sequel so no time wasted there and thank
you Ryan
all of them Vlad too late Johnson said
it will be centered around Daniel
Craig's epic take on a southern
detective Benoit Blanc investigating a
new case the role of Benoit Blanc Aaron
Craig a Golden Globe nomination and when
we Ryan Seacrest asked him about it on
the gloves our carpet Craig said he
wouldn't say no to doing a sequel so
that's a yes right okay so we should
point out that Lionsgate hasn't
officially greenlight a sequel to knives
out but the surprise hit is one of the
highest-grossing films of 2019 that
wasn't a sequel or from a franchise so
hooray for originality knives out made
nearly 250 million after a reported
budget of just 40 million so the cases
of detective Benoit Blanc could very
well become a franchise within itself
which is great because it's really fun
listening to Craig do that southern
accent something he told us all about
when we sat down with him a while back
and I just wanted to get the accent
right so I worked on the axe I didn't
work on the script I worked on the
accent with everything I read you know
reading the side of a cereal package
anything but inden the accent
and since Daniels wrapping up a very
successful run in the Bond franchise
when no time to die hits theaters in
April it's the perfect time for him to
step right into a new long-standing role
maybe knives out can throw him like a
couple of action scenes next time
and along with more Daniel Craig we can
expect another great whodunit story from
Ryan Johnson the director of the
certified fresh' Star Wars the last Jedi
has proved that he isn't afraid to push
the envelope when it comes to giving
audiences what they're not expecting as
far as the rest of the cast goes with
Craig potentially on board there's
really no other characters from the
first film that would need to be
involved although I'd love to see Anna
the autumn eyes come back who also
earned a Globe nom for her performance
and it's fun watching her and Craig team
up together otherwise the sequel will no
doubt bring a whole new batch of big
names and killer performances much like
we got from stars like Chris Evans Jamie
Lee Curtis Toni Collette Michael Shannon
and Don Johnson the first time around
and hopefully we'll get more quotable
lines like up you're a very back and
fans on social media seem excited as
well with users like Matthew on Facebook
saying things like this is so smart he
is an instant classic character but
other people like Oscar think that they
should just leave it alone it was great
as a standalone movie ah the endless
movie sequel debate I suspect all right
friends it's time for you to weigh in
now are you excited for an Icehouse
sequel or do you think they should make
like the Beatles and let it be let us
know your thoughts in the comment
section and for a full list of golden
tomato winners and to vote in our fan
categories please vote it's so much fun
head on over to Ryan Tomatoes calm
alright friends thanks for tuning into
the weekly ketchup on youtube make sure
to tap that subscribe button in
notification bell so you don't miss any
future episodes at the ketchup as always
omnes Prez and we'll see you guys next
week
[Music]